ja Befreiung ist das große Schlagwort
das derzeit die Ukraine prägt nämlich
Befreiung der besetzten Gebiete von den
russischen Invasoren und wir sehen uns
hier erstmal Bilder an von gestern aus
einer Schule in der kleinen Stadt Miro
ljubisca sehr kleine Stadt in der Region
im Süden des Landes hier sehen wir wie
ukrainischer Soldaten das Schulgebäude
was durch die Kämpfe völlig zerstört
wurde erklimmen und dann oben drauf die
ukrainische Flagge hier hissen auch
diese kleine Stadt wurde gestern befreit
nicht nur Sie sondern zehn weitere
Städte allein gestern in der Region
herson befreit wir gucken uns das ganze
mal auf der Karte an bzw wir gucken uns
erstmal an wie die Ukraine hier vorgeht
nämlich sie hat eine Strategie
angewandte die die Russen als Tentakel
Strategie oder als als Octopus Strategie
bezeichnen nämlich sie gehen überall mit
kleinen schnellen Manövern voran sie
umgehen die großen gefestigten Stellung
der Russen eben in dem ein Panzer vorne
fährt wir sehen hier mit einem
Maschinengewehr schießt mit einem mit
seinem Panzerrohr schießt und ihm eben
hinterher kommen dann die ein die sich
schnell an den Russen vorbei bewegen das
ist eine Art blitzstrategie wie gesagt
die Russen sagen das sind Tentakel weil
es eben immer bloß 20 30 ukrainische
Soldaten sind die in kleinen Truppen so
schnell an den russischen Panzern vorbei
gehen und einen Stellung Vorbeigehen
dass man ihn überhaupt nicht nachkommt
und die Russen ziehen sich dann zurück
und wir sehen jetzt hier einen
russischen Panzer einen alten t-62 der
hier am Straßenrand steht ja nicht mal
zerstört aber offenbar hat auch eher das
einfach nicht geschafft hier Widerstand
zu leisten und ist jetzt einfach von den
Ukrainern hier
sozusagen passiert worden wir schauen
uns das ganze auch noch mal an was die
ukanada benutzen nämlich nicht bloß
Panzer sondern auch eben aus dem Westen
gelieferte gepanzerte Fahrzeuge das sind
hier sind M113 und wir sehen jeder M13
das mit 1 2 3 4 5 6 mit 10 Soldaten
vollgepackt diese kleinen schnellen
Einheiten bewegen sich durch die Dörfer
an den russischen Stellungen vorbei und
schneiden dann den Russen den Nachschub
ab von von ihrer von ihrer
Nachschublinie wir sollen uns das ganze
auch mal auf der Front auf der Karte an
um zu verstehen was diese Tentakel
Strategie bedeutet nämlich dass man
nicht wie bisher wie sie auf versucht
haben die großen Städte zum Beispiel
hier Carson direkt angreift oder
novakarovka sondern dass man versucht zu
sehen wo ist die russische Front am
schwächsten wo kommen wir dran vorbei
und die Idee die du keiner jetzt hatten
die sehr gut funktioniert ist hier oben
entlang destiniert bevorzugen und eben
von hinten wenn man so will die
russische Front aufzuräumen und die
Russen müssen sich dann dementsprechend
zurückziehen das also die Situation in
Carson doch nicht nur da auch im Osten
des Landes wissen wir trinkt die Ukraine
nicht Armee weiter vor da haben wir die
sehr erfolgreiche Offensive ein rakeaf
gehabt vor wenigen Wochen jetzt der
gesamte Norden von donetz Kiel befreit
mit der Stadt Lühmann und wir haben eine
weitere Offensive die jetzt hier nach
rakiv geht auch dort also weitere
vormärzte der Ukrainer und wir wollen
uns mal ansehen und anhören vor allem
wie die Ukrainer in der Stadt burowa die
befreit wurde das Ganze feiern und wir
sehen hier zwei Frauen wir hören uns
vielleicht mal die endlich nach 7
Monaten wieder durch ihre Stadt fahren
können mit der ukrainischen Flagge ja
bisher war das ja Todes auf jeden Fall
wenn man so will und eben einfach feiern
dass die Russen gegangen sind dass da
niemand mehr da ist hier vorne sehen
wenn einzelne Fahrradfahrer viele
Menschen sind natürlich geflüchtet aber
sie fahren hier durch ihre Stadt und sie
gucken sich an was davon übrig geblieben
ist und das Interessante ist hier wieder
die sind die Russen sind so schnell
geflüchtet dass die ukrainischen
Zivilisten herauskommen konnten mit
ihren fahren bevor die ukrainische Armee
da war das heißt hier ist es quasi
Niemandsland wenn man so möchte kurz
darauf etwa drei vier Stunden später kam
dann die ukrainische Armee dazu und hat
die Stadt dann auch formell unter ihre
Kontrolle gebracht hier sehen wir
tatsächlich die Leute ja sind jetzt hier
in im Zentrum der Stadt und wir sehen
auch am Rathaus gleich auf der anderen
Seite vor das Hauptplatzes wurde jetzt
hier die ukrainische Flagge schon
angebracht da sehen wir sie hier nochmal
um zu zeigen da die ukrainische Flagge
angebracht wieder ans Rathaus nach
sieben Monaten russischer Kontrolle aber
es ist noch kein ukrainischer Soldat da
insofern diese einzigartigen Szenen die
wir in den letzten Tagen immer wieder
sehen die ukrainische Armee rückt so
schnell vor versetzt so sehr die Russen
im Panik dass sie einfach fliehen und
flüchten aus den letzten Orten die
Zivilisten zuerst sich freuen und kurz
danach diese Städte wieder unter die
Kontrolle der ukrainischen Regierung
zurückkommen
[Musik]